excusé aujourd'hui on se retrouve de
nouveau sur le cumul strict pour jouer à
un jeu d'horreur ça fait longtemps n'est
ce pas j'aurais aimé que ça dure encore
plus longtemps
on est donc sur affectait sur aurore
experian se voit là y'a des objets
qu'ils veulent on sait pas trop pourquoi
faut sélectionner un niveau sur
l'expérience complète souvent choisi bon
on va commencer par le commencement le
manoir oui je n'ai pas trop de courage
et alors c'est bon je suis dedans
quelqu'un a reçu un colis mais ne l'a
pas pris qu'une maison bien gai comme on
les aime un n'est ce pas ok ce qui se
passe pourquoi on est là
inquiète la diaconie pour vous bon ça va
là il ya tous les éléments glauque d'un
film de rob
non personne ne sortira d'ici
par contre moi je viens pour livrer le
colis ok avec la petite fumée comme on
aime pas trop où est ce que j'en ai
complètement pas parce que je sens bien
cette porte va se refermer en trop lent
à je suis à l'affût
tél montrons des choses je l'avais dit
que j'étais à l'affût
je le sentais bien que la porte que
c'est que ça aux [ __ ] bien sûr le
tout pour invoquer r comme roller eu
comme uppercut
n comme non au comme oh [ __ ] tu vas
mourir a plus de lumière comme oh [ __ ]
tu vas mourir watts d'un bateau mais
c'est le jeu plus est les petits de la
planète quoi annoncer mon quinquennat
qui est là 1
le guide c'est une visite oui tu guide
guide moi c'est ton métier plus tard
c'est lui extincteur c'est de tuer le
guide
qu'est ce qu'un cette pièce peut-être
une petite fille qui veut nous tuer
sauvagement un tiroir à ya des bruits
il ya des vieux bruits de pas
nathan a été le bruitage à un moment
donné ça suffit moi je énervé si vous
continuez je m'énervais où je vais
devenir le guide
voilà je vais voler ton métier à
bon bah je te laisse ton métier alors
alors une petite fille avait l'air de
rire vert ici j'ai une petite fille je
viens en paix tu as volé le collegium
petite fille je viens en guerre
l'ambition d'être venu là où j'étais
mais non je ne viens pas vous vous
n'aurez pas je suis un livreur en bonne
santé
un ouais la porte se ferme c'est bien
j'aime bien ça ça ses débuts une bonne
fois et ça et tu chantes chantes chantes
ce fut une fête un peu un peu seule voix
la personne n'est venu à la fête
finalement arrête de chanter au les
chrétiens non c'est un ouvrier
elle a fait la technique du lauriers
alors qu'elle a fugué au nom au nom tu
es venu pour la soirée
c'est dans l'autre pièce petite fille et
tu cherches touche
si dans l'autre pièce mais je vais la
laisser seule dans l'autre pièce dite
adja [ __ ] j'ai quitté le jeu se fait
exprès ou alors je vois tu ouvres ta
paix au métier de gros cons ou et la
mallette voici l'endroit où la file a
décidé de crier voilà je sais pas
pourquoi elle est probablement plus de
panache et elle a fait sa petite crise
de petites filles allons lui acheter du
panache ya pas de panache et ans et plus
tard étagères du panache et pour la
fille qui crie salut c'est ici la soirée
mais pas pourquoi le jeu d'horreur à
chaque fois que j'ai peur j'ai vu l'asie
quelle soirée on est pas sur les voies
la mgm est ce parce que la cinquième
soirée [ __ ] un week end soirée elle va
elle va bondir de nulle part je le sais
je le sens et là bas non c'est une
chaise mais ça fait peur aussi une
chaise des fois un bon jour en droit de
l'ol après tout pas lâcher [ __ ] mais
oui mais c'est ça il était fâché pour
panacher voyez bien le frigo il n'y a
plus rien toutes les palettes de pommes
et les oranges mais les pistes un acteur
que fais tu ici tu ne tue ne me fait
toujours pas visité au en eau
non il ya trop noël a fait je suis au
moins seul avec un extincteur plus de
place plus de place pour toi et c'est la
porte du
de l'arrêt cardiaque au dos pitié bon je
sens que toutes les lumières toutes les
lumières vont s'éteindre bien évidemment
aux hutus va survoler oui j'aime bien ça
la valse des meubles ça me plaît après
avoir dansé dans la mer surcôte il a
tort il danse ont l'air sur affected bon
je m'en vais je m'en vais je m'en vais
aller mais maintenant êtes-vous ya un
truc qui marche et un truc qui marche
d'enfer où je mets bien votre valser
mais bien repassée au nom au nom qu'on
n'y a pas de son cv il va y avoir un son
qui va me faire peur très peur
c'est la porte la porte est fermée
tu as donc qu'un complice je m'en
doutais et l'extincteur
ils étaient dix ans il était diabolique
elle est juste là je chante avec toi et
mais je veux juste aller à droite et tu
vas pas du tout le kidnappé il ya un
peuple qui me bloque et à gauche aussi
alors je vais délicatement tôt je me
suis fait de combat tueur je suis cassé
le cou non mais l'incroyable quoi cette
fille là sort de nulle part comme celle
qui sur les gens puisque plus de panache
et [ __ ] vous n'invitez jamais dans vos
soirées
ja mais est ce qu'on fait l'asile
maintenant un mois ça m'intéresse ça
vous intéresse alors nous sommes
intéressés bonsoir censeurs ok c'est
quoi ça qu'ils ont greffé des organes au
mur propose concours maintenant que
c'est courir profitons c'est bien on
s'enfonce un peu plus dans le sol penses
tu de sécurité à attention retour en
arrière impossible après cette porte
eh ben c'est très bien souvent et
partout dans l'ariège à la la ces des
cris de bébés bon ça trouve c'est par bb
sus quelqu'un qui a une voix très aiguë
qui a jamais muet mais
annoncé à justin allard bout d'un moment
qu'elle porte la porte sont humides dans
laquelle des gens sont morts ou la porte
et que les réussites dans laquelle des
gens sont morts la portée que le lait
c'est quoi ça oh et 20 mai qu il y avait
un mec qui faisait la chaise compte au
bio il se muscler un peu les abdos et
crois qu'on l'a pas vu mais si on l'a vu
ce que ton ventre et jolie maintenant un
doute on veut tout savoir
ça ne m'inspire pas trop confiance je
propose d'aller faire la chaise avec
l'autre homme je sais y'a un moment va
sursauter surtout faut que j'achète
manettes d'un mauvaise idée en tombant
c'est à ce que d'appuyer sur un bouton
et quitter le jeu encore plus tard mais
qu'est ce que je fais tu sais que ça
s'allume equator laissait même pas un
trou si j'te papier pas une qui se
rebellent quoi nous voulons changer de
mieux alors ça suffit papier pas ça va
bien se passer
ça va mal se passer c'est bon c'est aux
hommes est vite conclue après qu'ils
aient tué un homme de l'ombre est là
pour le coup c'est vraiment nombre de
l'ong goal mais qu'il entrait dans un
endroit que mon lit mais ça sonne
screamer et est ce que je peux lui faire
peur moi si je vois que je prie avant
lui il a entendu quelqu'un comme ça
tranquillement va regarder l'eau je le
fais peur oh oh non il se fait kidnapper
devant nous tous nos rouge sauf le bon
et c'est vrai qu'il n'a peinons à bail
est mort voilà je ne mourrai pas ici à
côté de lui je mourrai plutôt plat je te
fait peur où je mourrai plutôt ici à
côté de ce tonneau tu vois maintenant ou
jamais alors va chier pauvre homme sans
habits offrandes des abysses je tente et
meriem un peu bizarre droite ou gauche
droite gauche mais non mais qu'est ce
qui se passe ici pourquoi encore un
homme pendu alors qu'est ce qu'il ya
dans cette première cellule un homme
mort dans cette deuxième cellule un
homme mort dans cette troisième cellule
à l'escaut la tête contre les murs et
mignon ça me fait penser à votre liste
son crâne a l'air si doux finalement
bombe a continué après avoir vu des
jeunes gens un peu partout
je suis sûr que ce parquet a été fait à
base donne morts tout est fait à base
d'eau morts ici c'est génial a même en
position foetale qui a mal à la tête je
suis sûre il passé entre le mec mureaux
tout est terminé plus on foetale salut
emmerdes des barbelés partout quoi les
mecs qui se barricade
ils mettent du barbelé en se disant non
à l'homme sans habits de matha fera pas
oh [ __ ] des bombes a volé quoi je veux
dire on peut aller dans ce protégé
gratter le dos la veille a pas de
problème
wells en aviez passé [ __ ] médias nous
dire bonjour un peu un oh non pas comme
ça je parlais d'une feinte belle et
heureuse au sur fauteuil roulant [ __ ]
qu'est ce qui m'a fait il est là des
petits bugs
il sait pas trop comment se tenir dans l
échange des postures bon ça va se finir
sur nous a évidemment arrête de bouaké
depuis un an le screamer la non réaction
la pression monte ça va être là
maintenant voilà j'étais bon j'ai plutôt
vu ça comme un homme nu qui faisait un
show à quelqu'un cette partie pour le
carnival bienvenue dans un cirque qui
attendent plutôt un cirque lodge est
absent que c'est une sorte de dressing
mélanger que des ruines à la ces se
passe dehors
le cirque et par là haut a dit dos est
ce qu'un tonneau rouge se cache dans ses
poubelles et qu'il essaie de montrer
qu'ils en kilos enfermés là dedans y at
il quelqu'un un clown à un présentateur
de cirque un jeu c'est pas un truc ça me
ferait plaisir à ceux reste trois clowns
qui me répond depuis ta caravane
j'arrive alors oui dessus tu n'est point
là à tuer peut-être là finalement
peut-être vais-je me réveiller dans ton
lit il est là ça lui est alors
maintenant navire mais qui fait débat ça
cartonne arrête un mois quand quelqu'un
fait quelque chose que je veux pas du 10
juin avec toi et ça n'a jamais marché
mais bon ok a cassé la caravane très
bien bon il est un peu un peu fou quoi
oh oh oh oh pardon pardon qu'est ce qui
se passe et c'est l'explosion c'est par
là regardez this way il ya un mec que
fait-il c'est un cheval qui mange un
humain ça suffit au revoir monsieur
gauthier à cheval mais par le coup quoi
voilà un fou de moi j'ai pas trop
comment le prendre ce que je suis pas
bon ils vont chez l'ex et voilà en plus
on se moque de moi non mais j'ai compris
c'est bon quand est-ce qu'on voit un
numéro à la fin on est là pour ça c'est
parti c'est l'entrée ni kent en hausse à
dos je vous jure ça me fout mal la has
est un labyrinthe
bon on arrête de te moquer le mec qui
fait que nous troller tout le temps mais
ce qu'il prenne la première alors on
apparaît en haut d'un truc un toboggan
je suppose une grande roue c'est une
grande roue qui a l'air pas trop marché
d'ailleurs la maintenance la maintenance
et sa mort mais nous on
opt à l'attraction up to devant la
bouche du clown digestion pour lui mais
où seul c'est fini c'est fini
bombard l'agencé jazz funk vidéo sur
affectait le gesppe actions déjà plus et
qu'elle s'était pas vu la vidéo ça fera
plaisir
ça faisait un bail que j'avais pas faire
un jeu d'horreur avec le recul c'est
vrai que c'est vraiment immersif quoi
comment coryez inscrits mis un terme en
la vision que le mec est là voire même
la voir même l'or n'hésitez pas à dire
dans les commentaires si vous voulez que
je fasse d'autre jeux d'horreur avec le
plus ou même des jeux what the fuck et
tout ça parce qu'on se retrouve très
vite dans une nouvelle vidéo tient tout
le monde puisse bien joué elle est belle